I be flossing
and I be flossing
I be flossing
I'll be flossing genius needs to be
stopped
genius wishes aside that as far as I'm
concerned used to break down rap lyrics
explaining the meaning behind the song
giving more depth to the artist but now
genius have taken on new ventures hit or
miss I guess they never miss hop the hit
is the slang for heavy what you got a
boyfriend I bet he doesn't kiss yet
Wow well what does that mean the joke
here is that Roberts not wanting to kiss
what I want to know the meaning behind
this it's disgusting
well now instead with the genius or rap
genius or whatever you want to call it
instead of having respectable artists I
deserve recognition they decided let's
add Viners like little poems and Gabi
Hannah and of course the backpack kid
so essentially going from not many times
I got to tell you I'm a man in the
mission many times I got to tell you I
don't need no permission a human with
supervision a new living condition I'm
reaching out to my children just hoping
that they would listen start a new
coalition against corrupt politicians is
not enough hot to pissing to many murder
convictions another family evicted
another black man a victim that's as
real as it's getting you should take
recognition Jew I be flossing
and I be flossing
and I be flossing
I'll be flossing I'll be flossing I'll
be flossing I'll be flossing I'll be
flossing what does he mean by that
finally I can understand what he means
with I be flossing
this is a ton of great memes from this
now they clearly just given up hey
there's a ton of stuff to go through but
why don't we start with the IB flossing
song just because we're already brought
it up for convenience E I'd be flossing
what does he mean by that
Fossen is the dance that took the world
by a storm on the Internet washing the
dance that took the world by storm it
just really came to mind like I was just
like playing around in the mirror
playing music and I started dancing and
then I started doing it and I was like
whoa that's a cool rhythm to it as I
just notice Instagram the Dames it just
really came to mind you mean when you
were browsing YouTube don't lie to me
floss kid everyone knows the original
was from 2014 huh do you want me to do
it again okay
[Music]
the dance just really it just came to
mind I don't know it's just so random I
don't understand I'm joking obviously
I'm not saying he actually plagiarized
it a lot of people are saying that he
did but obviously it is possible for two
people to come up with the same day and
smooth I know crazy to think about right
I think that's why it's so funny to me
that he actually or ace parents or
management try to copyright this dance
move that it's not even original
everywhere you go you will see that Foss
and dance everywhere you go you will see
the flashing dance come on it is hard
isn't it I'm cut again there yes just
keep keeping three nuts so the craziest
place I've seen the floss dance probably
like in New York there is a little
Guinness Book of World Record thing that
they were doing for the amount of people
flossing at one time and it was like 700
something people and they didn't invite
me but it's okay wait wait a minute wait
a minute sorry but did you say that
700,000 people try to do flossing in New
York City and this was recorded before
ninjas now it all makes sense doesn't it
didn't he just say that they were trying
to get a million people to do the floss
in New York City so we're gonna try to
get a million people right now to dance
in time so they were trying to beat the
floss record but no one did it imagine
trying to break a world record to get a
million people to do something this this
brings a whole new meaning to this whole
thing that's amazing but no one does now
I get it
this is how bad ideas come to mind when
you try and steal some other person's
idea that doesn't make any sense just
like you try and steal the dance I'm
just kidding I'm being too harsh on this
kid I mean like it's a cool dance I am
NOT saying he didn't come up with
international you will see it in France
I want to go to Paris honestly the
Eiffel Tower
that's great content perfect example of
why I love right
genius well I love genius it'd be
international you will see it in France
the Eiffel Tower
why did you write this very what was the
deeper meaning behind it I want to go to
France
that's great content left to right left
to right left to right okay left right
left right left right alright so the
first thing you want to do is spread
your legs and then you want to put your
arms out and go left right go left right
to right left to right
incredible everyone what it motivated
you and your mom to sue for tonight um
it was really my mom and my management
that did the lawsuit I'm kind of just a
kid having fun in life I'm just letting
the adults to all the busy work I don't
really know the law like that so I can't
really say if they're like taking
advantage of me or anything like that
but like from a mom standpoint like a
manager standpoint they think that
they're taking advantage of me how come
well you can sue everyone just go ahead
just go ahead please don't sue me though
yeah this is the real reason no one
philosopher and ninja speak they just
didn't want to get copyright strike I'm
not falling for that I'm not doing the
flux as copyrighted I know this is a
kind of a dead meme it's so goddamn good
literally sounds like the beginning of a
it's funny cuz it's true really they
don't know what I made really they don't
know what made of maybe I don't know
really they don't know what I'm made of
so that line people want to talk when
I'm not around here means a few things
one is obviously like gossip and rumors
but a lot of just two out
people want to talk when I'm not around
to hear really they don't know what I
mean how much meaning can you fit into
this I'm tougher than you think but it
also was supposed to be a deeper meaning
on DNA what DNA are you talking about I
don't want to be too harsh on Gaby I
mean everyone's being really mean in the
comments going like oh she can't sing
blah blah blah I mean let's be real here
so many artists can't sing and I hasn't
stopped anyone so keep doing what you're
doing Gaby because the memes are great
hey listen to music that I feel is
vulnerable really really jacob satorious
has a genius why stop oh my god looks
like they've just given up things just
completely given up haven't they these
are all this is four days before the
flossing whine all right let's see what
he has to say yo you actually have saved
me with this song there's nothing that
beats that Oh God this argument oh yeah
yeah yeah
like if at least one person got this
song and said it saved their life then
that has brought meaning to my work like
imagine being fifty or being an adult in
the future going like I'm a survivor
oh you survived the camps no but Jacob
Satori are saved me Thank You Jacob
you're musically many Australians my arm
a little with my [ __ ] who doesn't care
about my health like you do baby all I'm
saying is me and my managers are in LA
we go eat food every day and I'm so used
to the same thing where like the waiters
are okay well can I get you they're not
happy with their job there I mean it's a
job and you know like people got to work
but at the same time like you should be
happy with what you do it's nice to know
that people care about you but sometimes
your waiters you can be okay if they
don't are you saying I'm more confused
now when he explained it there's must be
some really advanced lyrics for the
record though you don't have to have
advanced necks but if you go in genius
then maybe you want something to say at
least but what is this he ordered a coke
waiter with my coke who doesn't care
about my health like you do baby all I'm
saying
you order the free first of all you
order the coat is that what you mean can
you be and what's the thing about you
should love your job like why ever what
every waiter is supposed to be happy
Dappy serving you coke not everyone can
make a living making from musically
videos and horny tweens like Jesus
Christ dude if you want someone to worry
about your health man then maybe your
management that you go eat lunch with
every day like I don't get it maybe I
don't get it maybe his stuff is too
advanced for me oh I wouldn't mind if
you wanna be together get back together
yeah I I'm alright but I'd rather be
alright with you you just give up I
rather be together my job is to be a
singer if you don't like your job then
you have a bad problem
I can't keep your ripping into these
kids alright I get I don't want to be
bullied
alright Jacob do whatever you want
alright I'm trying to stop you live your
life be free man order Amy as many cokes
as you want
don't let anyone hold you back maybe
consider Coke Zero now you look like
your skinny boy you could probably drink
regular coke lily ponds when lovely
pause was ingenious I knew it was over
and I get you have to understand that
this video comes from a place of
disappointment I mean I really like this
series I really like genius I really
enjoy watching different artists and
rappers explain their lyrics
I don't like lily ponds Hey look there's
my comment large G Ike's how did we get
here
me hi Leonard did you know I'm latina
just letting y'all know she's latina
legend has hit lil is doing you know
clearly you don't have to have just the
serious art is on here I wouldn't like
that either that would just be annoying
you need a bit of contrast in there and
I respect genius for doing that but
Viners please for the love of God stop
gaping buy a nurse a platform
not not saying there's a ton of great
Viners on this platform like drew Gordon
has great videos danny gonzalez all I'm
saying here is there is actually
talented funny smart people that came
from vine but it's a desperation that
really gets me it's like clawing for
relevancy that it's just so gross to me
they always seem to crawl their way into
the corporate world somewhere even Lille
extinct like I don't generally hate her
but the desperation just disgusts me and
it's so transparent with these miners
it's just sickening I don't like it I
don't want to see it as I mean I hate
them personally or whatever they're
doing I just don't want to see them and
I can't avoid them they're crawling
their way into my territory my genius
reviews okay just stop so let me just
end up by reviewing some of my favorite
genius reviews that are actually funny
we have big shack for example ah
boom now that's genius
and you're not wonderful with a sugar
like me when I pull up in that Maserati
I had a minivan it's great my absolute
favorite one has to be the lil yachty
peekaboo boosters make that sound mellow
nosedive hmm if anyone can transcribe
that for me please do because I have no
idea what he just said you need to
really pay attention which is why it's
so important to listen to this now the
best break no either okay about that
Square we played each other Squidward
played the clarinet you're a musician
okay hope you guys enjoyed this genius a
rat I keep calling it a rap genius it's
clearly not what it is Viner genius
that's right that's the thing apparently
you guys enjoyed smash you like if you
did I would really appreciate it
get some merch everybody it's now on 15%
sale that's right see if you ever want
to buy merch me like I don't know maybe
I don't have no now's the time baby get
done merged fam get it don't get it guys
you can get that subscribe to PDP merch
or maybe the 70 million club merge or
maybe the suka Fiat merch
oh wait we don't have that or maybe the
pew nerds March I don't know
ton of options check it out I also want
to give a quick shout out to my man CJ
plays okay this guy makes incredible
videos now I reviewed one of his videos
before apparently he's been a little
scared of making more videos so I just
wanted to hope that CJ gets encouraged
to make more videos I genuinely think
they bring a lot of joy to people so
shout out to my man CJ and I hope he
keeps uploading that's it for me for now
see you guys next time bye bye you want
pyramids
we got them oh you're into casos huh we
got you covered baby you want some bets
easy we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit
[Music]
you